okay here's my advice to 16 year old man
I get a lot of 16 year olds watch my
YouTube videos and they comment and say
I'm 16 what would you recommend I do in
this in that situation so listen if
you're 16 first thing I want to say is
this everybody wants to give you their
advice everyone's like you should do
this you should do that let me advise
you you're just 16 if you are 16 here's
what I will say only take advice from
people that you want to be like so if
you're getting advice from someone who's
broke loser goes down the pub every day
or just miserable in a nine-to-five job
that they hate but for some reason they
just think they can tell you exactly
what you did your life mmm-hmm need to
look at people that you want to be like
take advice from man next qualifications
are massively overrated I really believe
that I mean I am you know I'm an
employer so I take on a lot of members
of staff I think we've got like 36
members of staff right now and I really
don't care that much in my members of
staff when they come for the interview
if they've got really good
qualifications if they've got like first
degrees and stuff I don't care I only
care about one thing that's how much
value can they bring to many so if
you're 16 or young and you thinking okay
shall I go to university to you know get
all these qualifications which might
serve me one day qualifications are
massively overrated what's underrated is
your skill and your value that you can
bring to a company or to a business okay
next is dream big man I don't know why
people tell you not to dream big anymore
I mean when when you're a young kid like
when you're six you want to be an
astronaut you want to go to space you
want to be a billionaire you want to be
a Hollywood movie star you want to be on
TV you want to be a multi-millionaire
property investor all this kind of stuff
and then for some reason life tells us
as soon as recently leave school and we
get 16 18 20 actually that's unrealistic
listen life is super short you're great
your tombstone will have two dates on it
and a dash and the dash is what you're
in right now life's too short to dream
small so what I would say is dream
massive massive big dreams don't let
people tell you you know that's
unrealistic come on if anyone's ever
done it before then you can do it as
long as you put the work in and
you make it happen so dream really big
and then every decision that you make so
I'm not like a dense University if
you're thinking don't go to university
do this dream real big and then you
dream life that you want only make
decisions today that are gonna help you
get closer to your dream life so if you
want to be a doctor then for sure man go
to university and studied it be a doctor
and get all the right qualifications if
you want to be a property millionaire
you don't need to go to university you
just don't so figure out your dream life
and then only make decisions today that
are gonna help you get closer to that
dream life also work massively harder on
yourself then you do want anything else
so Jim Rohn says work hard on yourself
and you do it on your job the more
valuable you can come don't wish it was
easy I wish you wish you were better the
better you can become the more valuable
the more experienced you can become the
better you're gonna be in in life and I
think lastly what I would say I want to
keep this nice and short is do not care
what anybody thinks about you that's it
man that would be my number one piece of
advice don't care what anyone thinks of
you because ultimately you know most
people spend their whole lives worrying
about what other people think of them
what their parents think of them what
their school friends think of them what
their colleagues think of them but
they're not responsible for your life
you're responsible for your life they're
not gonna be the person that has to put
up with you for the rest of your life
when you in a job that you hate they
aren't gonna be the people who have to
deal with the decisions and consequences
that you made they're gonna be either
long gone or long forgotten about or
doing something different focusing on
their own lives so don't worry about
what people think don't care about
whether you fail or not because value is
just one step closer to success and if
you look at all the super most
successful people on the planet they all
failed many many times so what I would
say is just dream big go crazy don't
care what anybody thinks work harder on
yourself than you do in your job get
education become valuable and go kick
ass that's what I would say to a 16 year
old will say if you're 16 you want to
come to the property investors crash
girls do it you should you'd be better
off going if you want to be a property
you know property millionaire or you
want to do something that's like not so
conventional as a business person don't
go to university to study business
because the teachers that are teaching
you business aren't running successful
business
doesn't make any sense I only take
advice from people that are doing what
you want to do so what I would say is if
you want to be a business person you got
to be a property person then rather than
getting credited education rather than
going down the university wrote route
and spending 50 thousand pounds studying
to get a piece of paper you're much
better off to put that in to invest that
in education is actually gonna give you
the skills it'll be a lot cheaper it'll
be a lot better the marketplace is not a
just or racist or discriminative like
the marketplace all it cares about is
can you bring the value so if you're 12
years old but you're able to find good
deals then you're gonna get paid well
you have to figure stuck up that's all
that'll really investigate but it
doesn't care where it comes from
it's just if the return on investment is
there it would be stupid not to go free
they'll look at the deal did you get did
you get your guys did they sound like a
nondisclosure agreement with it yeah I
expect so you because you know you know
what happens these big players these big
investors they'll take advantage of
people 15:16 what happened today so we
found a deal 21 percent ROI Wow
21 percent ROI these guys are like 15 16
did you enjoy the day yeah what would
you say to other teenagers that are
thinking to come to the crash course how
long is it gonna be before you guys it's
not much of a risk dude it's a free
program but how long will it be before
you guys are financially freed you
reckon
you can check out the whole video the
interview up here if you want to come
down to the property investors crash
course and learn the skills that will
help you become financially free in
property you can do that book on right
here and of course don't forget
subscribe over here thanks guys
subscribe I'll see you soon